let g of x equal one over x can we use
the intermediate value theorem to say
that there is a value c
such that g of c is equal to zero and
negative one is less than or equal to c
is less than or equal to 1 if so write a
justification
so in order to even use the intermediate
value theorem you have to be continuous
over the interval that you care about
and this interval that we care about is
from x equals negative 1 to 1.
and 1 over x is not continuous over that
interval it is not defined when x is
equal to 0 and so we could say
no
because
g of x
not
defined
not defined or i could say let me just
say not continuous
it's also not defined on every point of
the interval but let's say not
continuous
over
the closed interval from negative one to
one and we could even put parentheses
not defined
not defined at x is equal to zero
all right now let's ask the second
question can we use the intermediate
value theorem to say that the equation g
of x is equal to 3 4 has a solution
where 1 is less than or equal to x is
less than or equal to 2. if so write a
justification
all right so first let's look at the
interval if we're thinking about the
interval from 1 to 2
well yeah our function is going to be
continuous over that interval so we
could say g
of x
is continuous
on
the closed interval from one
to two and if you wanted to put more
justification there you could say
g defined
defined
for
all
real numbers
such that
x does not equal zero
x does not equal zero i can write g of x
defined for all real numbers such that x
does not equal to zero and you could say
rational functions
like one over x
are continuous
at all points in their domains at all
points
in
their domain that's going really
establishing that g of x is continuous
on that interval and then we want to see
what values does g take over at or what
values does g take on at the end point
or actually these are the end points
that we're looking at right over here g
of one is going to be equal to one over
one is one
and
g of two is going to be one over two
is equal to one over two
so
three fourths is
between
is between
g of one
and
g of two
so by
the intermediate value theorem
there must be an x
there must
be
an
x
that is
that
is
in
the interval from
we're talking about the interval from
one to two one to two
such that
g of x is equal to
4.
and so yes we can find we can use the
intermediate value theorem to say that
the equation g of x is equal to 3 4 has
a solution and we are done